[Music]
the reason the loaning included us in
their attack was that they thought we
scholars who read foreign books in tort
foreign culture were liars trying to
mislead the people and make way for the
Westerners to exploit Japan so we also
became their prey one of my colleagues
in the government service Tezuka rich
suzhou had a really narrow escape once
when he was visiting the headquarters of
the Choshu clan he'd made some mention
of foreign affairs but that the young
men in service on the estate taking him
to be an outspoken advocate of free
exchange suddenly fell upon him to Zuka
ran face life followed by the young men
with drawn swords unable to outrun them
he saved himself by leaping into the
moat Nebbia though it was a cold season
for swimming yet i could not think of
giving up my major interest or chosen
studies i decided that it would be
useless to worry over the predicament
in the midst of such disturbances within
our land England demanded satisfaction
for the murder of Richardson
the British fleet arrived in Edo in the
spring of the third year of bong queuing
to present their formal demands these
terms required the payment of one
hundred thousand pounds by the central
government and twenty five thousand
pounds by the clan of Satsuma and the
execution of the murderer before British
Representatives a period of twenty days
was fixed for apply this indemnity
document came on the 19th of February as
I was one of the interpreters in the
service I was sent for at night to the
residence of the Minister of Foreign
Affairs in Akasaka with my colleagues I
worked till dawn
translating the long letter from the
British all the while we were afraid to
think what might be the outcome of our
own translation two days later the
Shogun apparently unaware of the
imminent crisis set out from Edo for
Kyoto to visit the Emperor with the
Shogun absent naturally any decision of
the government had to wait soon the
period of twenty days had expired the
confusion in Edo was becoming acute
people were sure there would be war that
many residents prepared to escape to the
country there were even rumours as to
exactly when the shooting would begin
there was another postponement of 20
days then 10 more days of grace while
the government kept putting off an
answer I felt that war was inevitable
after all and began preparations for
escape to a safer position than my house
in chin Senza the end of the last
postponement drew near and the British
declared that there could be no more
putting off even for a day as I was in
the Bureau of translation I knew every
detail of the situation and the suspense
was unbearable
once I was ordered to translate a letter
from the French Minister the Belcourt
I don't know what his purpose was but
the minister made a downright assertion
that France was absolutely on the side
of England in the present problem and in
the event of open hostilities the French
fleet would be ordered to bombard Edo in
alliance with the British
our government was simply worrying about
the threats and bullying of the European
diplomats and could not decide what to
do as matters became more acute the
senior officials pretended they were ill
and none of them would attend the
conferences
two days before the absolutely final day
of reckoning I gathered together my
furniture and made ready to move to a
Aoyama
where a friend the physician Kure koseki
lived as I passed by the drill grounds
on the seashore of shin Senza and
noticed the cannons turned seaward ready
for action
I believed war was inevitable at that
time I had several students staying in
my household and had on hand the sum of
about 150 Ryo in gold two blue coins as
we might all be separated in the rush of
a fleeing crowd I thought it better to
divide this money rather than to have
myself or my wife carry all of it
together then each one would have
something to rely upon in a crisis thus
equipped we were ready for the next
day's war but an unforeseen event
happened one of the senior officers in
the government set out from Edo in a war
vessel his vessel was promptly followed
by an English gunboat it was reported
that the English boat intended to fire
if the Japanese vessel steered straight
out to the sea because the minister and
made it known that he was sailing to the
province of the West unexpectedly the
ship veered to Yokohama the minister
landed and went directly to the British
Minister the minister handed the hundred
thousand pounds indemnity in silver
coins on his own responsibility the
crisis was over between the countries
for a while the next move of the English
was towards Kagoshima the capital of the
Satsuma clan to demand a further
indemnity of 25,000 pounds for the
family of the deceased and the execution
of the man who had killed Richardson the
English officers Admiral Cooper
commander Wilmot and captain jostling of
the flagship then waited for the reply
when it was long delayed they decided to
commandeer as their temporary security
the two ships which Satsuma had
purchased from Europe they're about to
tow these ships out from their moorings
near the island of Sakurajima in the bay
when in sudden retaliation the clansmen
on shore opened fire the English ships
returned salvos and thus the Battle of
Kagoshima began
one of the largest of the round shells
exploded on deck and killed the
commander-in-chief from the captain
besides wounding several others the
English fire in turn was quite to us
destructive and most of the town near
the seashore was demolished yet after
all there was no decisive victory after
they had made peace and paid the 25
thousand pounds the Englishman casually
asked them to return their salvaged
anchor the Satsuma officials without a
second thought evidently delivered the
anchor as if it was so much scrap iron
this sample shows how little the
Japanese knew of international ethics at
that time from the very beginning it is
doubtful whether it was reasonable at
all for England to demand the sum of
125,000 pounds for the death of a single
man although it is now an affair of
thirty years ago when things without
precedent were happening daily we
Japanese still feel the injustice of
that demand and settlement when the
Satsuma men proposed a truce what
enormous threats and boasts the British
Minister made and how naively the
Japanese believed or were afraid to
disbelieve indeed the whole issue was
closed before the Japanese people really
knew what they were up against even the
Americans were saying at the time that
they hoped Japan would not pay the full
amount and when I recall how the
Minister from France came out with his
most amazing threats I begin to doubt
the sanity of the men concerned from the
Imperial Court in Kyoto there was issued
an edict that beginning on the 10th of
May
the third year of bunk you the expulsion
of all foreigners was to be enforced it
seemed as if there was nothing but aunty
foreign agitation in the country the
Shogunate was now harassed on both sides
there was on a one side he agitated
clans which clamored at the point of
arms for the closing of the country and
on the other side was the united power
of Western nations demanding the
open-door the Shogun at as the governing
force had lost all its prestige there
were almost daily assassinations the
country had become a fearful place to
live in in this state of affairs I tried
to live as discreetly as possible for my
chief concern had become how I might
escape with life and limb in the third
year of kayo I had the opportunity again
of going to the United States of America
it was my third voyage to foreign lands
some years previously when the Shogunate
had considered obtaining some warships
they had requested the American minister
Robert H crane to negotiate the purchase
and handed him the amount of $800,000 in
several payments in the third or fourth
year of the Bunko era one vessel named
the Fujisan had been delivered the cost
of this had been four hundred thousand
dollars since then various Affairs had
occupied the government and the civil
war in the United States have broken up
her foreign interests and so the
delivery of the second ship had been
much delayed it was decided to send over
a mission to conclude the purchase of
the second ship and also to obtain some
rifles for the army
this video is sponsored by Squarespace
the best site to choose if you want to
set up a website or increase your online
presence Squarespace has been a
long-time supporter of content from the
history brothers and of education in
general on YouTube and other platforms
our website is still in the planning
stages but Squarespace is of course the
company we are turning to to help us out
as I've mentioned before I'm a bit of a
Luddite
so having their guiding hand is exactly
what I and my Nokia 3310 need with a
simple interface and sleek looking
results including blogging tools to keep
people updated and easily understandable
analytics it really is the best place to
go if you want to expand your brand so
take advantage of the free trial and
head over to Squarespace comm forward
slash vs. for 10% off your website or
domain thanks
[Music]
in this same year a regular packet
surface was opened between Japan and
America the first vessel to arrive was
the Colorado and we took passage on her
return voyage it was a fast
steamer of 4,000 tons veritably palatial
in comparison with the small boat on
which I had previously crossed the
former had required 37 days the rapid
liner arrived in San Francisco on the
22nd day there were as yet no
transcontinental railways so we embarked
again for Panama by the Pacific
steamship company line after a weight of
about two weeks we cross the isthmus by
train and then again took ship to New
York our voyage ending on March 19th we
went directly to Washington and called
on the Secretary of State at once to
proceed with our deal the way the
business was done certainly illustrates
our government of those days it would be
supposed that before we sailed from
Japan the mission would have had a
receipt for the $800,000 that had been
duly paid but in reality there was
hardly anything that could be recognized
as an official voucher our files
included some 10 pieces of paper with
simple notations of $50,000 $100,000 etc
but there was no statement of how or for
what purpose mr. prawn had received the
money among the papers were several
oddly shaped sheets with nothing but the
amounts and the name Prue you inscribed
the American parties might easily so
inclined have assumed a skeptical air
and refused to honor such pieces of
paper
there was much discussion among the
members of the mission before the voyage
but they decided finally that this
apparent neglect could be made a proof
of friendship between the two countries
Japan had trusted the American Minister
rather than the Japanese government had
put its faith in the goodwill of the
American government and no formal
agreement was deemed necessary the
papers were simply memoranda in which we
would not place any importance having
decided upon this attitude which was due
to the force of circumstance when we
opened the negotiations we were greeted
at once by mr. Peron himself without any
hesitation or formality he wanted to
know if we would take a ship or have the
surplus fund returned the mission felt
relieved at this fine attitude of the
American ex-minister we were taken on a
tour of inspection and finally decided
on a steel craft named the stone wall
later called by us as Zuma Kahn then we
purchased several hundred or several
thousand rifles still some seventy or
eighty thousand dollars of our fund
remained and this we left in the care of
the American government it was not until
the following year the first year of the
meiji era that the ship reached japan
then with the new year in early January
came the Battle of Russia me the defeat
of the Shogun's army and the retreat
back to Edo of Shogun Yoshi Nobu himself
again great confusion swept the country
and this marked the beginning of the
Imperial restoration though I did not
engage in politics I was not entirely
ignorant of the political world on the
voyage to Europe I used to talk over the
problems of the time with the other
interpreters man Suki and Mr curry what
do you think of it I said one day the
Shogunate cannot hold the country
together much longer it seems to me that
all the clans might get together and
form a federation like Germany what'd he
say to this idea Matt Suki and Mizuki
agreed with me that this would be the
most peaceful solution to the crisis
then going on to talk about our own
careers I said if I should say what I'd
like to do if I could I would like to
become tutor to the big chief with a
salary of 200 bales of rice a year and
the chance of teaching him all the new
ideas of civilization and bringing about
a great Reformation to the country
[Music]
but to return to the contemporary
situation in the country I noticed when
I looked around that all the ronin
adventurers and so-called Patriots and
collected in Kyoto around the Imperial
course the Shogunate in Edo on the other
hand was trying to keep its own as the
central government against this rising
power these two political forces had
come to be called Kiner the supporters
of the Emperor and Sabah ku the
supporters of the Shogun if I may sum up
my position between these two sides
number one I disliked the bureaucratic
oppressive conservative ante foreign
policy of the Shogunate so I could not
side with it
but two yet the followers of the
imperial cause were still more
anti-foreign and more violent in their
action so I had even less sympathy with
them number three
regardless of right or wrong an
ambitious man might cast his lot with
one or other of the parties to win a
place for himself for in a troubled time
one can best do a big thing but there
was no such desire in me
[Music]
another instance of the stubborn
conservatism of an official may be
pertinent here I was reading chambers
book on economics when I spoke of the
book to a certain high official in the
Treasury Bureau one day he became much
interested and wanted me to show him a
translation I had once began translating
it when I came upon the word competition
which there was no equivalent in
Japanese after trying several words I
was obliged to use an invention of my
own Keo so literally race fight when the
officials saw my translation he appeared
much impressed then he said suddenly
here is a word fight what does it mean
it's such a non peaceful word that is
nothing new I replied that is exactly
what all Japanese merchants are doing if
one merchant begins to sell things cheap
his neighbor will try to sell them even
cheaper or if one merchant improves his
merchandise to attract more buyers
another will try to take the trade from
him by offering goods of still better
quality thus all merchants race and
fight and this is the way money values
are fixed I understand now but don't you
think there is too much effort in
Western Affairs consider that too much
effort all the commerce of the world is
conductive fundamentally like that yes
perhaps went on the official I
understand the idea but that word fight
is not conductive to peace I would not
take the paper with that word to the
chancellor for his judgment from the
gentleman's exception to my rendering of
the term I suppose he would rather have
seen such phrases men being kite to each
other in a book on economics doubtless
the official would have approved a book
that advocated man's loyalty to his Lord
a love of the nation shown in connection
with trade open generosity from a
merchant in times of national stress etc
from this little incident one may gather
the character of the other officials
whom he represented in the government
when the invading army did come however
it proved to be very well disciplined
and no unreasonable violence was ever
done peace and a stable government
established in April of that year my
school structure was finished
[Music]
it may see that I was unreasonably
severe in hatred of the government but
the whole reason of my stand was that I
believed the new government to be
carrying out the ancient policy of
exclusiveness
and antagonism against Western culture
and I feared that the change from
Shogunate to Imperial regime would bring
no good to the country I have never told
anyone of the dire helpless state of my
mind at that time but I will confess it
now watching the unfortunate condition
of the country I feared in reality that
we might not be able to hold our own
against foreign aggressiveness yet no
one in all the land was there with whom
I could talk over my anxiety no one
anywhere east west north or south as I
searched whom I could depend on as I
look back today over thirty years since
it all seems like a dream how advanced
and secure the country is now I can do
nothing but bless with a full heart this
glorious enlightenment of Japan today
[Music]
[Music]